Let's go next to our caller from the nine
one nine area code nine now nine one nine.
Is that North Carolina maybe.
No, it's country code 91, I'm sorry, who's
calling from country code 91?
Hello, David, it's me.
I'm from India.
I need it from India.
Lovely.
OK.
Yes.
What's going on, my friend?
Hello.
Yeah.
So I was just going to ask you about.
I already started up this thread.
You know, the recent comments by Trump about
calling fallen soldiers suckers and losers.
The idea has been that the community vote
will decrease because of that.
Because I saw segment by you.
I thought I'd been by you were on bonus that
we were talking with Pat about how it was
very easy really, that a Republican and you
think that this will just even decrease his
support by voters in the military?
I do think so.
I don't know that it's going to be a big impact.
But I think that, you know, we have that Military
Times poll from a week or two ago pointing
out that right now members of the military
are leaning Biden by about six points.
I have to believe that even if it's not a
huge impact overall, that a few more point
percentage points of military members are
going to get away from Trump because of the
quadruply corroborated story that he called
members of the military who died suckers and
losers.
I think it will affect him in terms of his
support within the military by a little bit
at least.
Yeah, and what do you think of others, like
more sycophantic followers?
They just want to live in denial about it?
Yeah, they do.
With everything else.
Yeah.
The sycophantic followers will just say it
didn't happen and they'll continue living,
you know, living their lives and supporting
Trump for sure.
Yes, it's crazy.
All right.
Thank you, David, for taking my call.
Wait, so hold on a second.
So, as always, you know, what part of India
do you live in?
Oh, I live in south.
Yes, I'll be there.
They've been going on.
And what is life like there?
Well, I guess they're they're copying the
US's idea of the pandemic is over, we're not
going to do anything further.
And I guess if you undertake this, I just
wear masks.
And yeah, I just had to actually I had to
go out to take a picture of the sunset, something
so many physics lab and you can just see,
like, everything is normal.
No, I think some people are wearing masks.
But if you just came in and you had no idea
what was going on, you wouldn't you wouldn't
think anything other than.
Yeah, I guess people are just wearing masks
more now.
And it.
Did you.
Have you lived in an English speaking country
or is your language proficiency simply from
learning English in India?
Oh, yeah.
My language proficiency proficiency is simply
from learning language in India.
That's I was going to add new diversity in
the States, but some.
That is incredible.
I couldn't because I just.
Yeah.
And so I am bringing university in the States,
but I have to stay here because of Cauvin.
So I hope I get in the spring.
I would be going.
Yes.
All right.
Well, listen, I really appreciate the phone
call.
It's great to hear from viewers all over the
world.
Yes.
I'd love to hear from you and congratulations
on nine hundred ninety thousand subscribers.
Yes, nine ninety is nice.
One million I think will be a nice round number,
though.
Let's go.
All right.
Thanks so much, appreciate the phone call.
Thank you.
Wow.
Caller from India.
Love it.